uh so he's she skis and you're coming
here
are you doing me you pass her
you see and now your choreography
takes that step and then you shove them
straight forward
again i pass the
i'm passing the rotation axis of the
technique
of the uke nage
dynamic okay i pass
that axis of rotation
and then i just accelerate her i'm on
this side of the axis of rotation
and now i accelerate
this does not work because it's just an
acceleration technique
and as you saw i pass it again
the athletic person just walks out
that's not it so let's first find the
kazushi
let's look at the position okay
the fight is going to rotate
here and i need this leg to come forward
this leg
try to find the access mundi of this
technique
it's already not back here it's already
it's already forward
okay she's gonna go forward
boom you see
that it's not here though it's not here
it's gonna keep going
you see you see it and now
their head goes this way and the hip
goes that way
okay there's no place for her foot to go
look at it again
she has to come forward but not directly
in front boom
then the energy boom
she's going around she's gonna go around
so i'm not just turning her and then
pushing her
i passed it it's working hard i don't
care about the technique now
just the poverty
that's not the technique where i touch
that's the technique where the energy
goes
okay so i'm going to turn this
head goes around me boom push
okay just learn the power get in the
place where the head can go around you
and you make the hip go
12 30 12
1 area not where the head goes
okay try it the throws always
aikido throws the arms are redundant
stance is redundant to arms over down
which means one arm can do the throw by
itself
okay it's just not marginally valid to
not have redundancy
in your technique okay so let's look at
the arms doing that pattern i know i'm
just gonna grab her a collar this time
okay and i'm going to do one arm does
the pattern
just move yourself where the pattern is
going to be so
i'm going to make her come forward on
the other foot
and into the technique
is moving forward hips forward
and around
don't pull her back in so you go forward
you get back to balance
the energy goes around
so this forward energy is still going
forward
when i start to turn it do you see that
energy is still going forward
just to make it work i have to get the
head below the hip
energy and then that creates a
topsy-turvy effect
so if i do the same thing here without
lowering it it doesn't do anything
so i have to lower it at a rate where
the hip
energy the hip inertia is now traveling
and an x to the head and the head
inertia
going around me so
and you'll get that same position
pattern okay so let's just
work on the arm portion
this part here but we're just going to
grab to do it
okay and you're going to start to
discover where do i have to be
for that to happen okay where do
i have to be in relationship to the
overall spiral between naga and nuclear
okay go
so if you watch this
is this the hand here this time oh
morning
just working on that angle
if i'm too far forward i'm going to do
the same thing with my
arms the energy goes off too soon
doesn't work too far forward
you could exaggerate this and you could
see the back hair
it's not going to do anything it's not
going to do it okay
the technique the axis of rotation for
the whole technique
is not empty
okay try it again all right and uh now
we'll do the front arm
okay so again if i
because it's a redundant system if i do
the front arm
and i'm in the box you're gonna run out
of steam
okay so the front arm has to do the same
thing
so it has to go this way
okay
can't go here that's just shoulder get
her hips moving
so not this way she'll just run out run
out
this way
okay okay now go slow enough that you
can catch
where you change the pattern okay so
she's doing ski to my face
not to my face through my face
right you go slow and do it and she's
going
and i'm doing the pattern
you can see she's still falling on the
same geometry
in the same deconstruction of her face
your arm goes dead that's why you come
in and get your leg
and you go put self protection or keep
your arm like you're going full speed
again you're very self-preserving
okay try it again okay so yesterday
we had the guy question please get in
punching for me and we had the guys to
show
you uh that i'm not using their forward
progress
to do the technique okay so we had the
arm extended but they're
not going with me right remember that
they're bracing backwards
brace brace you got it they are doing
that
okay so she's bracing it doesn't matter
she's gonna go
you see i'm gonna show you another one
because now you think you need him to go
forward
she's not going forward i'm letting her
go forward
okay so uh she tries to go forward she
can't go forward
go go she can't she can't go keep going
she can't go forward can't go forward
she's trying to shove as much as she can
she can't go forward she can't go
forward i do the product
i'm not getting out of the way and the
bull goes by me
i'm controlling it okay so pull
cancel forward oh go ahead
it's all just the ground pass you can't
go forward can't go forward
and i'm doing in her body in her body
can't go forward can't go forward don't
pop okay try it
okay so what what i'm trying to show is
that
she can't run out of the technique and
get off of my
axis monday for the technique okay so
i'll do the noggin i'll be there again
okay and i'm gonna do the punch
i'll punch through and then just keep
walking okay
and i passed the axis wendy for the
technique
did you get it i just i'm
not doing anything but i keep walking
she can't pull my head down because i'm
not there
it's not because she's not strong enough
you're going to see it again
i keep walking if i stay here she has
the angle
but if i keep walking past this she
doesn't have an ankle
so the technique here is that even
though i'm yielding
she can't go forward she can't go
forward
not gonna let her by me whoa we can't go
forward go
can't go forward two half can't go
forward two points in control
we stay here all day these things can't
go forward
you can just project back
i control the degree of penetration
and the rate of penetration you can't go
forward okay
so you're going to try to run out of it
i'm going to take the washer i'm just
going to run out of this
come back
a home can't go forward kind of go
forward
can't go forward i'm going to start
compromising posture
but you'll see if i go like this and i'm
behind her you see
she can run out of it
so
okay she's trying to go forward there's
a lot of pressure on there
oh i'm controlling it i'm now in her
body and i do the rotation
she tries to walk out can't go you see
[Music]
oh in the body you looks like she could
go by look
if i let it go she can go by
whoa
okay try it again this is the internal
aspect
go